Vsauce.
Michael here with good news. Today we've got
two Leanback experiences, where we pull together great
videos from people all over YouTube.
The first, here on Vsauce with me,
is roughly gonna be about complexity.
But over on Vsauce2
Kevin has put together an exhibition of fantastic
street art.
To begin, all you have to do is click the link
at the very top of this video's
description. And to start Kevin's Leanback
go over to Vsauce2.
Click the link whenever you're ready,
but in the meantime,
let me show you this.
It was submitted by a
fan named Aaron and it shows the cast of
The Key of Awesome.
But wait, who's this hot body with great cleavage?
You guessed it, the bearded nun.
Aaron, this is gonna be
on my refrigerator for the rest of my life.
Thank you.
Are you guys still there?
Seriously?
Because you should start the Leanback.
Click the link at the top of this video.
I'll see you on the other side.
And as always,
thanks for watching.